ah
[Música]
i
y que notes luz conecta el mar
mediterráneo con el mar rojo a través de
abismo de suez y tiene a un lado a
áfrica y al otro hacia tiene 193
kilómetros de largo después de su última
ampliación que se produjo en 2015 y deja
pasar barcos de hasta 240 mil toneladas
hace 152 años cuando se fundó solamente
barcos de 5000 toneladas podrían pasar
por esa vía tan importante con la que
transcurre en cada año entonces por
ciento del tráfico marítimo comercial
del mundo también el 7 por ciento del
crudo del gas natural licuificado y del
petróleo refinado pasan por el canal de
suez que es una de las vías económicas
más importantes aparecido y también un
motivo de orgullo
desde que fue nacionalizado por el
presidente nasser en los años 50 el
presidente al fatah al 6 y quiso
ampliarlo y duplicar una de las vías
para reducir el tiempo de espera y
permitir que más barcos puedan pasar a
diario y que tarden menos de 19 horas
que se tardaba hace unos años solamente
a 11 que es lo que tardan en la
actualidad
[Música]
rusia eeuu están muy lejos pero también
muy cerca donde se juntan asia y américa
al norte casi se tocan rusia y alaska es
el estrecho de bering su anchura es de
82 km desde 2012 la costa rusa del
estrecho de bering ha sido una zona
militar cerrada hoy hay proyectos para
unir ambas orillas con un túnel o un
puente que tendría unos 100 kilómetros
de longitud el estrecho de bering emerge
ahora mismo como un punto clave de cara
al futuro gracias a su ubicación
estratégica vincular a las economías del
océano pacifico con las economías del
océano atlántico norte pasando a través
del océano ártico que por culpa del
calentamiento global está cada vez más
libre de hielo en el ártico va a ser
entonces un punto de tránsito comercial
muy importante inicialmente a través de
la llamada ruta del norte que pasa por
encima de rusia
este paso ahorra a los transportistas no
sólo tiempo sino también combustible en
sus viajes entre asia y el norte de
europa
la ruta reduce el trayecto a menos de la
mitad
[Música]
esta ruta en el centro del continente
americano tiene más de 100 años
conectados océanos fue una obra iniciada
por los franceses en el siglo 19 que
concluyeron los estadounidenses en 1914
está en medio de una zona selvática es
una construcción de 80 kilómetros que
conllevó una gran labor de ingeniería y
que hoy cuenta con 5 esclusas son una
especie de cámaras que permiten subir o
bajar el nivel del agua que logran
vencer el desnivel entre el extremo del
océano pacífico y del atlántico millones
de toneladas de productos que
representan 6 por ciento del comercio
mundial transitan por estas aguas cada
año eso significa el paso de más de 12
mil embarcaciones por el canal de panamá
que conecta con 160 países entre los que
destacan como principales usuarios
eeuu china y japón- dato importante que
a diferencia de otras rutas del mundo
este canal cuenta con un equipo de
pilotos que toman las riendas de
cualquiera de las embarcaciones que
llegan a esta vida y la conducen de un
extremo a otro
[Música]